Peter Brown here with a gamespot news
update the free games for PlayStation
Plus and July have just been announced
there are a few recent high quality
games coming up and like in June there
will be two free games for each current
PlayStation platform the PlayStation 4
playstation 3 and Vita for PlayStation 4
active PlayStation Plus members will be
able to get towerfall ascension which is
a great game to play with friends and
Strider a fun 2d ninja platformer
PlayStation 3 owners get dead space 3
hey the most recent installment in the
action horror series as well as vessel a
physics-based puzzle game Vita gamers
get lego batman 2 DC super heroes which
has an open-world lego gotham city to
explore and the last game doki-doki
universe supports cross-play with
playstation 3 and playstation 4 so if
you've got a vita it's kind of like
you're getting three games for the price
of one all six games will be available
starting july second the same day the
current free offerings expire so make
sure to check those out all you have to
do is start a download on any of these
titles and it'll be permanently added to
your library so they can be played or
redownloaded for as long as you're a
plus member stay tuned to gamespot com